hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game uh that happened a few
days ago in the mpl indian chess tour i
was planning on showing it right away
where we were kind of busy with the
sinful cup but now that the sinkhole cup
is over it is definitely time to show
this it is something uh you've uh well
i've i've never seen it uh played in in
such a top level game these are all very
very strong grand masters narayanan
versus sarawind uh and what's more
interesting and what makes this even
more impactful and and painful is that
arvind was leading the tournament uh for
pretty much the entire tournament so
let's dive straight into it it's a very
short game but it has a very very
uh well uh
lasting conclusion uh so narayanan has
the white pieces and he opens with the
d4 we have g6 going for sort of a modern
uh
opening idea e for bishop to g7 we have
knight to c3 and d5 going into the
lizard the defense the mittenberger
gambit offering the d5 pawn but of
course you will attack the knight and
then you will win the d4 pawn so here
narayana goes for it knight captures on
d5 c6 we have knight back to e3 and now
queen captures and d4 we have queen
captures bishop captures and okay the
queens have been traded off knight f3
attacks the bishop bishop to g7 and pawn
to c3 we have knight to f6 and now uh
there is a game where knight to d2 was
played but here we have bishop to d3
and it is now as of move 9 that we have
a completely new game
so knight to a6 offering um uh bishop
characters and asics and even though
you you feel like you should play this
uh obviously arvind prepared this he
didn't play the
that uh gambit for for no reason he
knows what he's doing so maybe not
capturing would be the way to go and
here we have e5 attacking the knight
knight g4 now ready to put pressure on
this uh not there on this e5 pawn and
knight to c4 now adding another defender
to the pawn we have knight to c5 now
attacking the bishop as the wise did not
capture the knight bishop back to e2 and
now bishop to e6 putting pressure on the
knight threatening to capture it and
then of course win the e5 pawn so here
bishop to f4 adding another defender to
the pawn
and knight to d7 adding another attacker
to the pawn and here we have knight to
a5 here now narayanan says okay you can
have your a5 pawn i will have the b7
pawn and that's exactly what happens
knight g captures an e5 we have captures
uh sorry captures captures uh but not
with the knight with the bishop bishop
captures knight captures and now knight
captures some b7 so equal material
nothing out of the ordinary happening
here trading the central e pawn for the
uh for the b7 pawn we have rook to b8
chasing the knight away knight to c5 and
now rook captures on b2 so arvin wins a
pawn but uh he will have his pawn
structure messed up here as knight
captures on e6 happen so f captures an
e6 and now point four chasing away the
knight as the bishop is dominating the
knight on this half of the board so
knights to f7 and now bishop to f3
and if you look at the position now uh
well if you count the material black is
up a pawn but okay it's a double the e
pawn so maybe not all the relevant but
you do have uh
immense control over the second rank
with with your rook on b2 and here there
are a couple of moves that black can
play something like knights to d8 to
defend the pawn or even knight to d6
offer this offer this pawn for some very
exciting play but what you can't do is
what happened in the game king the d7
was played and it seems perfectly fine
you are defending the pawn but you have
blundered something much much greater so
feel free to pause the video here and
win the game on the spot while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
spotting this incredible idea and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course castles
that's the good stuff and it's not just
castles it is a castle's fork so check
and there off goes the rook and of
course as soon as aravind saw this uh he
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here
we can check it out once again we can
even do it in slow motion like this king
c1
castles with check and off goes the rook
and of course now you resign because any
move you make of course results in king
captures and b2 and now white is just
upper rook so
incredible incredible such a move uh to
be even possible on the board uh when
two such strong grandmasters are playing
but okay at least it wasn't a classical
game it was a rapid game but still when
around when arabian played it he still
had 13 minutes on the clock so this is
um absolutely spectacular so pretty he
pretty much blitzed out the entire game
up
up to this point and he is better here
uh he's the one who will be pushing for
a win but after king to d7 just castles
beautiful stuff
uh so i really wanted to show you this
as uh we've seen some czech mating uh
castles you know in the days of in the
days of morphe or or steinitz but uh
we've
i mean in 2022 such a move is is
definitely to be to be cherished and
also here uh like i said it was funny as
arvind was leading the entire tournament
so these are the final standings um just
to see so you can see that uh narayanan
wins the event and he has the exact same
points 28 out of 48 as aravind only uh
i believe the additional criteria of
course is their uh
their
individual encounter so of course as uh
as narayanan has won it uh therefore he
wins the tournament uh so really really
beautiful stuff then you have okay if
you're interested adivan in third mitra
ba in in 1450
and so on and so on so really really a
wonderful wonderful event but uh what a
way to win it like just castle always
always remember to castle everyone uh so
yeah uh once again i really hope you
guys enjoyed it i i would like to thank
revishing reptiles youtube uh another
casual coder david kimura john gear law
office and abdul rahman al-sawd for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank all for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions such as this
one and whatever else happens in the
chess world uh so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day